i don't know fraud or something
i mean falsifying the police report
three years bro
the funniest situation ever if you guys
i mean obviously we call it juicy
spoolie because of dave chappelle stand
up one of the funniest is that it's just
one guy said his name like that now
everybody goes juicy smoothie not
everybody literally read the headline
today and thought juicy smoothie
juicy smoke in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
got nick the ear and patrick dot heat on
riley wearing the same t-shirt like a
[ __ ] couple
why don't you guys just blow each other
off in the secret society
skirt society
society chapter 213 213. homie 69.
you're bringing it back you're bringing
back the secret society yeah so we're a
[ __ ] year and a half of just pain
because of um
coven yeah and uh that's been tough huh
been super tough i don't think like the
hardest part about doing secret society
for us is that we're very particular
about like fabrics and like sourcing
[ __ ] so you can't really shortcut
anything it does feel really good dude
yeah honestly the texture like it feels
really nice yeah all of our stuff can't
be shortcuted so if when supply chain
gets [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] we're just
we're just [ __ ] nothing where do you get
it where do you get the shirts from
where we did a lot of our current line
um the production was done uh domestic
and it's just it's just hell expensive
wow that's pretty cool you're just
bringing jobs to the u.s usa baby you're
a patriot for real there's nothing like
nike bro oh you know you're the opposite
i love nike
you make a great product yeah cool [ __ ]
yeah but we um we had to do a lot of the
stuff domestic and then some of the
stuff too it's not all domestic but the
ones that we did a lot of us cut and sew
like we have our own like spec [ __ ] so
it takes a little longer but you know
it's more
though
i [ __ ] love cause all my shirts they
all go to [ __ ] because they're all
cheap-ass shirts yeah but this one feels
different it's just like that quality
baby yeah it looks [ __ ] good on you
[ __ ] it feels like an american sold
this one that's a u.s that's a hulk
hogan
that's you dude [ __ ] yeah you gotta talk
you're an american hero
straight up man you're jocko willing
number two oh
yeah you're the korean wild [ __ ] will
nick is that his name
your name dude
dude we talked about nick
that's your name what's his name jack
jackal will of the cockpit
honestly no joke
gumbalaya
what is that [ __ ] gumbay
[Music]
i made a [ __ ] ton of uh mac and cheese
but your boy do it a little extra fancy
yeah
i always use cavatappi instead of the
macaroni what do you call it
hey
you only say that to italian ladies too
don't [ __ ] away and make sure you give
him a cavatappi before you leave
loose
why don't you come over here too like
why don't you yeah
what's stopping you why don't you what's
stopping you sorry
with uh
fontina cheese sharp cheddar and a
little bit of uh what's what do you call
that sweet three oh brie to make it a
little creamy oh wow damn and then i
throw a little roasted garlic in there
that i roast off myself damn yeah you'll
be roasting them i'll be roasting that
garlic and then we top it off with a
gremolata grandma
you guys don't know what a gremolata is
it's toasted breadcrumbs parsley
parmesan cheese and some lemon zest and
some salt and pepper or whatever there's
texture there's technique there there's
nice textures layers layers so you don't
need to bake it you just make the mac
and cheese nice and hot put the
gremolata on top it's super crunchy it's
delicious what did it sound like when
you were stirring it up oh it sounded
like you're getting your dick sucked
yeah
sound like that more dick sucking dude
sound like that good good
sounds like more like [ __ ] looking but
yeah you know
that wasn't my god dude
hey that's enough it hurts
you just pull the labias out you slap
him
we gotta talk about the [ __ ] ufc's
right now it's been a while since we
talked about the uff c's
that was a chamber and a religion
crested cat wow nice
gotta talk about one of my childhood
heroes jose
[ __ ] aldo dude
cozy
so was it you ufc 260 what
nine oh that's this weekend 269's this
weekend so the 268th oh no this was a
fight night it was i can't believe this
was a fight night by a great fight card
by the way
[ __ ] jose aldo if you guys don't know
this guy was like the
reigning champ for the longest time
until max holloway came in and took away
his bubba he honestly was the pound for
pound number one until connor knocked
him out yeah that's what that's called
connor yeah i don't know max hallway
kind of [ __ ] solidified it because
but after that like he had a run he beat
frank yeager
he won some fights in the ufc
and then max holloway came and [ __ ]
took that belt again two times he beat
him too so he really he really said sent
it home you know yeah but dude he's
still such a [ __ ] beast like for the
exp the time he's been in the like how
long his career has been dominant to
still be doing it how he's doing it and
also this is
uh like the pde situation like they're
catching [ __ ] left and right so
uh he's gotta be
all natural right but fools still could
be cheating i think he's still young
he's still 30 he's only 32. yeah he's
[ __ ] younger than me but like mileage
that he's had oh yeah he looked old
though his face looks like a baseball he
looked old like young aldo he looked
like oh this [ __ ] he looked like
a horny [ __ ] but now he's like
yeah he look horny dude damn she's like
horny you know like some angsty looking
dudes they just look kind of horny he
just needs to come he's been that's what
you thought huh
what do you still think rob font rob
which he's really good too
amazing
both these fools are actually kind of
big for the weight class dude when rob
font fought kobe kobe cody garbrandt
i was thinking in my head
i was like yo this dude is big as [ __ ]
gigantic and then when jose aldo fought
him this past weekend jose looked even
bigger yeah he looks so much bigger than
rob font they're both uh big for the
weight class so they have to cut a
decent amount of weight in so rob font
is known for his amazing hands his jab
but as we all know jose aldo has been
working with the navy yeah to get his
boxing hands ready he's been working
with the navy yeah the navy boxing team
like holy [ __ ]
oh okay so he's been he's been training
with them and you know i guess they all
had like olympic boxers or whatever but
that's why jose's hands have been so
[ __ ] good lately wow so he's been
cracking [ __ ] with his hands
and he's just i think like the thing
that people were concerned about number
one is number one rob font's [ __ ]
reach with his jab which was a big
problem in early on in the fight yeah
that timing cracking the [ __ ] out of him
the power difference was crazy
substantial i didn't real first of all
rob font hits hard
jose hits harder
he would just wait for this one little
opening
just
the right position so he could throw the
[ __ ] right down the pipe yeah cracks
him and then rob font wobbles yeah just
one hit and it turned the whole tide of
the fight over he's like and he stepped
into it he threw the jab break the guard
stepped right after with the cross
moving forward rob font's head hit the
back of his butt almost knocked him out
i think three times in the fight
it was it was rough and then and then
the low kicks is jose aldo not the best
slow kicker in the game
still got to be one of the best
when he decides to use it his timing the
like his situational awareness of when
to throw it and when to and to land it
and devastatingly
i don't think there's anyone better than
him he doesn't do the the upward flicker
low kick he [ __ ] rotates
and digs
so painful the way the way it connects
crap
and you know it's like some ufc fighters
when you see them like throw low kicks
and exchange them even when it lands
good like you're like oh okay like that
guy looks like he took it very well
right every time jose throws him spins
him around everyone's just like there's
a look on there like ah like i can't
talk about it like you know yeah like
[ __ ] if i get kicked again i'm done so
yeah
probably if you watch the fight like the
interesting thing is uh what i noticed
from uh even at the pedro munoz right
right he throws his legs down later on
in the fight yeah i think i think what
that's doing because he waits for the
queue for his coach to tell him low
kicks he doesn't ever throw them until
the coach till his coaches tell him now
well you would think too because so many
people know that he's such a good leg
kicker you've got to think that people
are waiting for it so maybe he that's
what he that's part of his strategy he's
like gets him thinking about the hands
and then round two three bang kicks and
you're like oh [ __ ] i forgot about these
bad boys because that's a whole nother
new threat that he has to worry about
later because like in the first two
three rounds was a boxing match yeah so
rob fonte's like all right we boxing
cool perfect i know i can excel at this
and he had a he did really well up until
that point and then until that big shot
landed up until that and even after he
got cracked rob font did a really good
job to recover and he came back and he
was he was he was on paper kind of out
pointing aldo
but aldo just was did such a good job
defensively where it kind of negated
that but once he landed the low kicks
like it was completely changed like it
wasn't really that close anymore but
even though rob fond is a tough
[ __ ] he hung in there but the
power difference was crazy if you
watched it just him hitting him with
whenever he connected that right rob
font's back of his head touched his his
the top of his back
just clap i was like clapping it's like
no that's just the back of his head dude
it was bad dude it was it was harsh and
his low kicks were spinning him the [ __ ]
around dude brutal just [ __ ] brutal
and the crazy thing is too it's like
it's it's nice to see somebody who's
fought for this long evolve his game
yeah right and evolve it in a better way
too
you know like because it's not like he's
doing anything too crazy
but it's like refined like it's just
efficient it seems like the best thing
about him too is that i was worried
about rob font against him because rob
font puts on such a crazy pace right
yeah and we've seen historically with
jose aldo crazy pace people [ __ ] his
game up because he can't get his game
going which was happening in the
beginning especially because rob vaughn
switches stance all the time he's
[ __ ] tricky he'll jab jab switch
switch to his other jab throw his other
cross with the left switch again it's
like this weird thing that he keeps
doing so i i thought that that's why
jose couldn't really throw those leg
kicks because his legs weren't as
available but rob font was doing really
great until he couldn't anymore yeah
the power difference was crazy yeah and
and all those guys like out of their
camp like the new england guys calvin
keator qatar and uh rob font they're
mostly boxing guys so it's like when you
fight them you kind of know what to
expect a little bit but man if they were
to like add a little bit more wrinkles
to their game as far as like striking a
little more kicking and just like better
placement i feel like these are easy
fixes for them that could excel them to
another level sure you know but it sucks
because you get a guy like aldo comes in
who's just a veteran in the game and has
such a well-rounded tooth like his
grappling yeah like he was grappling out
grappling rob font he's using his
grappling now yeah he's really and he
should be because he's so good at
grappling he's so good yeah i mean i'm
sure it'll be a learning lesson for this
dude rob font right he's still pretty
young right how old is he
i don't even know he's he's his 20s he's
his 20s right yeah so i'm sure he'll you
know he'll he'll learn from that do you
do you think that uh aldo can get a
title again
against um the little monster jaunt dude
i don't know if anyone dude that fight
was good him and yawn the first time
they fought was pretty much the thing
about that fight that worries me um if
they run it back is
jan
took all of the best shots it wasn't
like aldo was
wasn't landing or didn't have any
success in that fight it was just jan
does such a good job of like being able
to roll with the punches he like
mitigates the damage
but then just starts
like you said he's a computer yeah he
figures out what you're gonna do and
then just weaponizes it against you and
he's so like i
i've never seen anyone be so calm and
calculated in a fight under high
pressure consistently against the
highest level of talent and probably
arguably the most talent stacked
division in the ufc today
and then
like kind of drown these guys yeah like
what he did to corey sondhagen you know
like somehow i'm a big fan of cory i
think i think he was going to be champ i
still do
but when yon was able to just to like
kind of i gave corey maybe a round yeah
because the first round he was beating
his ass and then he goes
got it figured him out well he got
rocked what round did santa can get
rocked in he got rocked in one of the
rounds pretty good yeah and i think
after that it was kind of like it kind
of just started going down because it's
not like san hagen did anything wrong
per se no no he bought a great fight
dude he didn't stop first of all shout
outs to san hagen's [ __ ] cardio dude
yeah dude amazing because they're like
oh looks like he's slowing down he
doesn't look like he's slowing down it's
like he's getting frustrated
you know yeah he could find his rhythm
yeah yeah exactly and when he was
connecting he couldn't put him away so
that's like what are you gonna do yeah
he just didn't have the power to really
hurt him dude and then his transitions
jan's transitions from takedowns to
striking the in-between stuff like his
overall mma game is so good like he was
a world of sport champion
in russia that's like their highest
level master of sport and boxing so he
has such a decorated like his striking
iq is very different and then him being
able to
put everything together like his elbows
his boy tie his grappling all that like
he's a beast dude
he's scary like he's he's vicious like i
really don't think there's anybody that
wants to fight this dude like sean
o'malley was coming out saying like oh
yeah it'll be it'll be the biggest fight
i'm like you'll die dude i don't know
bro like let's see how you do against
like tyler phillips
against this guy this weekend
o'malley and [ __ ] san hagen would be
[ __ ] amazing
because stylistically they're very
similar so talented sean o'malley is so
talented he really is but with that i
feel like
we kind of saw in the cheeto fight a
little bit like once and even in the
chris motino fight chris montino is not
necessarily the best
striker and he has the best [ __ ]
face-to-face defense
like yeah dude what the [ __ ] your
abilities hundred one hundred yeah
but outside of that there were some
moments where i was like
kind of worried in that fight if sean
o'malley was going to give out because
the output he was throwing was so high
moutinho was walking him down and i was
like i wonder if he was going to like
wave her a little bit but he didn't to
his credit he didn't know but i feel
like somebody else that's going to be a
little more skilled like the guy he's
going to fight this weekend uh pavia or
whatever raw pavian he's really good i
think he might give sean o'malley some
work
but we'll see what happens we'll see i
mean sean o'malley is a [ __ ] animal
very good but he does have to start
fighting better competition like he's
got to start working his way up into the
to he probably said that he doesn't care
too does that worry when you hear that
from a fighter whatever well what i
heard i heard him on arrow helwani and
he was like i'm he's like i have like
two fights left on my contract
he's like i'll fight easy dudes and then
renegotiate for it yeah i mean that's
kind of a smart business oh yeah that's
true that's true i just don't care to
watch his fights anymore though because
i know the end result it's like i don't
care yeah i want because i think he's
good enough to fight the top 10 now he
is so i want to see it yeah you know but
then like just just from the mentality
wise right you still got like sugar
shawn o'malley and he says stuff like
that and then you see like a chemical
like give me everybody that's what i
think that's why we kind of think that
way is because it's obviously opposite
into the species even corey and he don't
give him a [ __ ] yeah he fights anybody
let's go yeah right that's who he is
yeah and the funny thing is too is like
his last two losses
she did amazing dude it's just sand
higgins you know the tj dillashaw
yeah like if they gave it to cory
sanhagen over tj dillashaw i have less
to say about that than the other way yes
a hundred percent yes yes 100 so i mean
even the way that he lost to p uh
piotrian didn't get knocked out he
lasted all five [ __ ] rounds and he
did really good it was good he lost but
he did again dude you know what i love
about piotr yanto not even his like
adaptability was how fast his pull
counters are
he's so quick timing everything it's
crazy efficient dude he's so beast it's
like even if you connect with him you
better [ __ ] defend or pull right back
out because he's going to crack the [ __ ]
out of you he's my favorite fighter
he's an animal more than [ __ ] fizzy
heaven [ __ ] uh well they're homies
they train together all the time i
didn't even know that until they started
fighting so brad riddell was the brad
riddell's uh adesania's uh training
partner he's a lightweight
former coach of tiger muay thai prolific
muay thai gym in thailand they're
they're the ones that do those crazy
tryouts with all the pro fighters that
come and they have a whole series half
the roster dies yeah and they just get
[ __ ] destroyed and then after brad
riddell left
fizzev fizz fizzev yeah phys physio
he came and started coaching and he's
the muay thai coach at uh uh
tiger tiger muay thai and he's the guy
that does the backwards kick where
someone throws the kicker right over his
face
yeah he's that guy that's sick sick but
like
the fact that people know him more as
that is kind of sucks but
because he's that type he's kind of
sucks it kind of teaches russia
because like he's so [ __ ] good his
striking is so good and the way he he
looked in that brad riddle fight man
like it was they were neck and neck the
whole time you could tell fizev had had
like the the upper hand it was so close
it was so technical
and then all it took was one big moment
that raphael threw where he was like oh
i know he does this
i'm gonna look for it he kept circling
to his left right right against the cage
so he said [ __ ] it he saw him circle
spin spinning back heel kick
right on the job
rocks him and he kind of like
malfunctions he does this yeah he's like
does like time out he says time out and
then he's about to throw on him and the
ref stops it but it was the it was like
it was like razor close the whole time
and the last round lasts like two
minutes he throws his kick finishes it
seals the deal finisher dude like this
guy is so good wow he's so [ __ ] this
on the same card
if you watch it because there's no crowd
you just hear leather going crap they
hit each other oh my god
many times like every time they
exchanged it was heavy in the pocket
they both landed but nobody wavered like
nobody nobody like their head
you couldn't even tell they got hit
unbelievable you know brad riddell was
doing something really great he was like
stepping in to his overhead and then
finishing it with the with the hook and
he was cracking
but i couldn't even tell it was cracking
him because they were both hitting each
other at the same time so i didn't know
who was getting hit yeah the only thing
you could tell is when they have welts
during the breaks i'm like oh so they
did get hit yeah because it was so fast
they were throwing everything there was
no pacing it was just let's go i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you it's their hobbies
they're zombies it's unbelievable how
much damage these [ __ ] can take
like even like one when i see a kick
like a muay thai kick land of the body
just one yeah like and you see like a
dude kick a bag like just in the bag of
beds in half like the fact that a person
can take that and still keep fighting is
unbelievable and sometimes smile at them
back then they smile like dudes yeah
like what the [ __ ] is that dude
made out of dude what the [ __ ] is that
that is crazy somebody who was [ __ ]
adopted at an orphanage and he needs to
[ __ ] fight for a meal yeah for sure
dude that's just like i just got
murderer in his veins dude like that's
insane you don't want to fight that guy
dude fight never [ __ ] we'll watch it
after this [ __ ] podcast i'll bring it
up and so you can watch them just
[ __ ] throw it's so good and you said
the other guy was the former coach of
the place and then he fought the current
coach yeah and that's gangster's fight
that's their home story they called each
other they were like hey we're getting
lined up to fight each other like you go
with this and he goes like hey i'd
rather fight someone that i know it's
all good we're going to be respectful
afterwards
how do you feel they're like a little
happy and a little sad because yeah i
had to fight my friend but that's not
what it looked like in the match bro he
was like you're trying to murder this
guy yeah yeah like the oozeman and
gilbert burns fight yeah that's crazy
boys they're [ __ ] their kids play
with you
yeah he talked about it
and he knocks him out and he just like
and and you could tell us like hurt
[ __ ] bro i'm sorry like because he ended
his homies dream kind of for at least
the temporary yeah usman is uh he has
ones
the michael jordan mentality yeah the
way he talks about even like that whole
gilbert burns and usman fight was
hilarious because he was like he's
trying to take food out of my daughter's
plate and the gilbert was like i never
said that
she's like what saying i never said that
i get that metaphor but not like
directly yeah
gilbert was confused i never said
anything like that he's trying to
[ __ ] kidnap my daughter and feed her
candy all day and rot her teeth
no dentists nothing no i was like he
really does the michael jordan thing
where he creates an enemy even if they
don't have to be i think they i think
yeah i think they all do oh at least
like champions like like like this the
great top like yeah that's how they have
to think you know what it says though
about the about about bobby green though
how much of a gangster he is because he
fought physio too and he was cracking
physio dude yeah that fight was crazy
i rewatched it because i remember
thinking i thought bobby green got the
better i thought bobby green won but i i
rewatched it and i was like oh i see
like in the later rounds i think fizzev
kind of got caught he kind of slowed
down a little it was just two rounds to
one that's what yeah but like in the
first two rounds i was like oh [ __ ] this
is like fizzif is kind of pissing them
up a little bit but in that last round
you're like oh bobby green just did i
don't give a [ __ ] let's go and that's
when he fights his best and he did that
to ali quinta yeah bobby is so [ __ ]
cool bro yeah
nobody's ever gonna fight like bobby
green like if you train with them and
they say hey we're gonna learn this
style good [ __ ] luck yeah right
that's not for everybody yeah because
his [ __ ] uh head movement his iq is
so high in terms of fighting sure it's
just you can't copy what he does hands
are at his [ __ ] waist he's slipping
and ripping everything dude pop pop
throws his jab out of nowhere moves out
the [ __ ] way people go for the
takedown because his [ __ ] uh he
stands so tall
[ __ ] shuts all that down very good
wrestler too yeah what the [ __ ] really
good wrestling crazy he started off as a
wrestler hey shout out to poirier for
knocking his ass out though yeah that's
true knock them out yeah that's right
bobby green's a crafty [ __ ] he's
a super crafty dude you know who i like
too that i don't even know if he's still
fighting was who's the groovy lando guy
remember oh he's really good he's crazy
[ __ ] too oh yeah yeah yeah sick that
dude's crafty didn't they fight and i
think bobby green beat them but i feel
like they fought they did but but yeah
that's another those two guys i'm like
those fools are kind of similar style
like they could easily be higher than
they are but they've had like some tough
breaks
was this he was the only guy that like
was really close to beating tony
ferguson
like when tony ferguson went on a team
yeah he was he was one of the guys that
got really close to beating and cracking
tony ferguson and everybody was like yo
lando banana's a sleeper but you just
kind of get the wins that he needed yeah
the same thing i feel like with bobby
green like bobby green like does good
good good loses but also the style right
like because when you have a style like
that you kind of leave a little bit up
to the unknown and it allows the other
guy to kind of rally but it's fun to
watch on from an entertainment
standpoint but like
habib's style is obviously the best to
like dominate or gsp style you know to
be able to control the fight and to
secure the win but those guys i feel
like their style doesn't really lend
itself that well when you get a guy like
a tony ferguson that's just so [ __ ]
crazy like if you fight a tony ferguson
you want to put his ass on his back he
just went he just tony ferguson if you
look at his like fight history
almost every fight that he won even on
his tear he almost got knocked out every
[ __ ] fight yeah he really did he just
that's true he's crazy [ __ ] just
crazy he would break people's will yeah
but he met somebody like justin gaiji
who is harder than everybody else and he
couldn't shake it off and that was the
other thing too
tony uh justin gaichi made him fight on
his terms yeah we've never seen him
fight that slow of pace no and and
justin gates he was just able to stand
on the outside and just pick him apart
yeah so like that was i think that's the
big difference and then everyone was
like oh that's how you beat somebody
first but then charles oliveira just
dominated him everywhere yeah but they
took him on the ground
too yeah yeah yeah dude but neil daryus
is fighting uh islam
that's a tasty fight dude but neil
daryus got hyped for that matchup i want
to see him hyped i want to see him
grapple he's like i'm excited yeah
i'm ready to go i think they're under
all the same management oh really yeah
and apparently like i think some i
forgot what podcast i was listening to
but they were saying how usually when
they all get together because they
usually have like management tours i
think dominance mma that's the ali abdul
aziz
so they all get together and do press
tours and [ __ ] i think they all train
with each other sometimes so i feel like
they've
definitely
wrestled at least a little bit or
grappled so i'm curious to see sure so
there must be something that the deal is
like okay let's go well but he has a
beast grappler he's a super he's an
animal but he's like yeah he i think he
trains uh out of gracie baja like
northridge with like all these really
good brazilian dudes homologo like some
really good his and and black house i
think he's part of black house
so he he's with some very good jiu jitsu
and his hands have gotten a lot better
too yeah mma mathematics
don't make sense i only know remember
neil darius because he took a fat break
i forgot what it was for but he was
probably injured or something i just
remember [ __ ] s and barbosa hitting
that [ __ ] with the knee
the prettiest flying knee ever going
backwards you know because he kept on he
kept on shooting that for the double leg
consistently throughout that fight and
then barbos was like not today modifoca
yeah
yeah knocked him out and said barbosa is
another dude who like could have easily
been champion at some point but just
cut it like at the final which is they
couldn't put it together
he doesn't evolve
yeah he's he has like the the same skill
set as uh [ __ ] jose aldo really tight
guard great muay thai some of the
fastest kiss you've ever seen
explosive as hell yeah refuses to evolve
though yeah so you know everybody's
grappling and wrestling has gotten so
much better and every and even like
frankie edgar was talking about edison
barbosa's grappling saying like dude
he's hard to take down well frankie
edgar is freaking out her size yeah now
sm barbosa is going to have to go in and
grapple with these people who are going
to [ __ ] take him down like he fought
her beep edson yeah like yet if he had
jose level jose aldo level takedown
defense
he probably would had a lot more success
in that division but he fought
um what's his name khabib who was
another wrestler that just beat him up
recently he lost again right oh kevin
lee like he didn't get beat up by kevin
lee but kevin lee had the wrestling that
was able to control the fight from the
last part and take edson out of his game
like that's that's what happens when you
get these really good fighters at the
top level i think you just take the
other guy he lost his last fight
recently too right uh [ __ ] yeah 145.
he lost to
[ __ ] he beat shane bergios yeah he
knocked him back
and then yeah that was like the weird
that was the last delay yeah um but the
last one who do you fight after that
giga was it giga it was giga it was giga
and but gigas gigas giga giga yeah like
yeah that's a great level z character
right now
that's a giga dude yeah that
[ __ ] is scary he looks old as
[ __ ] too but he's all dude right yeah
he's like is he russian too or armenia
or something what is he evil evil he's
evil i don't know i think he's like
he's getting the he's getting the uh
what's it called the chop the uh
chemayev treatment right now nobody
wants to fight him yeah calvin kater's
gonna fight him in january ooh i feel
like a fight that's a really good fight
i feel like calvin is gonna get his ass
beat just because
he's stronger than hands it's the tools
man yeah has he fought since uh
max holloway no
he took it off it's gonna be well that's
actually probably a smart move yeah all
that damage you need you gotta recover
january of 2020 yeah that's probably
good it's been a while dude it's a good
move though he needed to rest yeah he
broke off he took his head was like a
[ __ ] speed bag his face got a like it
was a max holly broke a record yeah yeah
like five face like five records hey
what we forgot to talk about this what a
great fight [ __ ] max holloway versus
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah we didn't talk
about this oh wow what a good we never
talked about that
let me tell you something dude
what oh i've never seen yair fight like
that ever that was incredible korean
zombie was beating his ass yeah this new
yair is so much better oh yeah i think
he knew he i think
this podcast is brought to you by stance
let me tell you something if you don't
know i'm an asian man with very large
feet and i need to cover my feet and i
always do it with my stance socks a lot
of people out there you got some basic
ass socks and every time you walk into
my asian house i see your dingy yellow
crusty ass socks with no flare design
and that's because you don't own a pair
of stands socks so many different
designs batman goonies star wars
whatever you name it and you should
probably gift it and my friends i'm
telling you they are comfortable give me
stan socks as a gift for christmas i'll
love you forever just know i'm taking
you home with me and i'm kissing you on
the mouth consensually and then marrying
you and then you'll die at the sweet age
of 89
and guess what we're gonna be burying
our stance socks stance believes that
the perfect fit matters more than
fitting in that those who feel good do
good go see for yourself register for an
account at stance.com and get 15 off
your first purchase use promo code brain
at checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance i think yeah you're one of those
guys that's like rise to competition a
little bit and max holloway is the
ultimate
he's like the a champ i think really
truly at the in the division right now
and i don't think he lost the vulcan
oscar the second fight nobody does yeah
he lost that [ __ ] yeah yeah so i feel
like he's the real that was like a title
fight in my opinion and for yair to
fight max i'm sure in his mind he knew
that he had to like
not let him get his rhythm off yeah like
there's not like and for max holloway
you know he's gonna be mostly boxing so
the kicks really helped yeah kicks he
was throwing he was able to keep his
range i think that kind of messed with
max a little bit like rhythm wise
but once he started getting his boxing
going
but also holloway doesn't check kicks or
what he don't bro he doesn't check he
was fine afterwards apparently he was
fine but like damn like it it's going to
[ __ ] you like oh yeah versus giga right
now dude that's a good fight that's a
good they're both their kicks are both
explosive as [ __ ]
i think you're really good bro you
already looked really good you see his
hands were good dude i was like dude
this [ __ ] [ __ ] throw dude he hit
holloway
with [ __ ] that would have knocked
anybody out yep the elbows like
everything he landed some shots were
like that's a ko if it was anybody but
he was up against the cage and he did
the up double yes
so nice and then [ __ ] holloway just
took it just ate it hate it it goes big
pop now that was a competitive fight
dude that's all the way through yeah
beast
and also max was coming off of injury
too you gotta injury that camp
so i i want to me when i watched
that's why the fight got postponed
because he got injured earlier and he
said he had to do a bunch of camps to
get into that fight but part of me was
like he just looked like he couldn't
really figure out yaya's timing a little
bit yeah awkward he was throwing so like
usually most guys aren't going to be
able to throw that many kicks and then
be able to fight five rounds
but and yeah here we had questions about
his like cardio a little bit you know
but dude i was throwing like a bag cause
i just been boxing so i started throwing
low kicks and it made me sweat 10 times
more yeah
i was like no more kicks
dude
it's just exhausting as [ __ ] yeah
there's just way more [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
you're rotating throwing the [ __ ] arm
and ripping the leg back as exhausting
as hell i just love hitting pads where
it was just boxing i was like i get to
chill you know yeah
muay thai pads i was like [ __ ] the
consecutive kicks consecutive kicks
and then you gotta do plum plum and then
spin motherfucker's knees
goddamn that's just tiring as [ __ ] i
don't know how people stay fat when they
kick box like because i'm even too tired
to eat they just yeah i don't know
anymore
that's it that's a simple equation
wait though i missed the days when we
had that gym we used to train but no
more man
we're about to find something soon find
something do you want to find something
i miss it so much man it was just the
right pace for me because i sometimes i
would just show up late on purpose
and i'd just be like what's going on
guys we're gonna get back and kick it
back in there
i hope so dude it's fun it's it's
different too because like kickboxing
too seriously i don't i don't like once
you get a good group that you could
train with yeah that's what's really
important because yes [ __ ]
trying to knock you out no that's
unacceptable yeah it's different man
like i've i've definitely
i've been watching like other gyms every
gym's different some of them take care
of you some of them [ __ ] don't and
typically what i've been seeing is at
the gym that has like ufc fighters
people are like entitled contentions
they're the killers they'll all knock
you out yeah that's just how it is
because baseline they have to be at that
baseline they're pros they're pros
that's the next level it's like a gym
that has like developing fighters and
they're great too yeah but they take
care of you more because they have more
of like a family environment
i'm like i i probably like those gyms
yeah it's a little more fun knowing your
crowd is really important it's also like
what are your goals you know do you want
to be in the ufc are you just trying to
get better and have a good time you know
yeah it's like if i me too i don't want
to go train with a bunch of pros and
like get [ __ ] cte i just want to like
train and have a good time hey when we
start wrestling doug
no professional wrestling professional
wrestling
i'm getting naked let's go
we gotta find some russian [ __ ]
i just gotta learn how to just do
something
i actually want marlin says he has an
extra ghee he was gonna get he was gonna
let me use it yeah i'm down marlin bro
marlon got tapped out by geo dude by gio
oh yeah he did got a little arm bar on
him right and that was a little ago bro
gio antoinette quan
this chick she's gonna be way better
than bart dog that's it that's on a
record you hear that quan dude nick says
you ain't [ __ ] dude
every time i see bart at jk news i'm
like bro your wife can be so much better
than you even no
i'll [ __ ] choke jio out right now i
don't know nothing about jiu jitsu oh no
dog that i think oh beat her ass dude i
think geo's going to triangle you
definitely before she even touches me
uppercut stop
over real quick she sits on the floor
like all right let's go come on
disengage nah low kicks to the legs
she's like
no kick to the leg
chop them chop them all day dude she's
gonna be good at jiu jitsu bro cause
she's long she's really athletic she
kind of gets [ __ ] i don't even like
hearing that [ __ ] we're starting to get
to next week yeah bro i will choke this
[ __ ] out so [ __ ] fast dude i don't
give a [ __ ] about her life dude she
wrote bart all the time too and barbie
he'd be roughhousing the dog doesn't
ever know how to play nice dude
he's yeah he's he's too buff sometimes
like he's just be tossing people around
even when we would roll like casually he
i don't do jiu jitsu this feels like
grabbing my ankles and he just chucks it
hella hard i'm like bro
and
he's a big strong [ __ ] though
the pretense is like he's like real
light
yeah explodes like the way he does it
makes it seem like he's going to treat
you carefully but he's lulling you so he
could just chuck you across dude i'll be
rolling them sometimes and uh
he'll like he'll we'll be in these weird
positions
and then i'm kind of like he's going
slow so i'm going slow right
and then all of a sudden he picks me up
and like throws me and i like flip
and i was like you [ __ ] dude
he's like
nice yeah like what are you doing are
you tossing me on my [ __ ] head i was
like all right [ __ ] just go hard
on him just go 100 on him all the time
yeah i think i'm gonna i think i have to
for my own safety
because he doesn't he doesn't kickbox
like that i don't understand why i don't
learn man and everybody that does jiu
jitsu because i'm not a big guy i'm like
what like 160 170 right now solid but
like
when you roll with certain dudes that
are way bigger than white belts and like
i'm i've been training for a while so
i'm like i'm not gonna like smash and
bail like i want him to learn i wanna
like kind of take him through the
emotions a little bit but then they just
try to [ __ ]
destroy you tell him to relax
i i can't tell him to relax so you just
gotta like sun them real quick like you
gotta smash their face in the mat like
you just gotta like kind of dominate
them or to put them in positions where
they can't do that to you because as
long as you could really get hurt when
you're not like for sure who you're
trying to chill next year i dedicate one
year of my life to grappling only let's
go i think you will like that start soon
because i've been i've been wanting to
go for reals next year it's all
grappling only and then i'll do
kickboxing after yeah dude and then we'd
like to do mma sparring at someone
else
it's so fun
it's the like when it comes to sparring
it's the premium
just having
having a dude against the wall or the
cage and just socking him in the face
it was so fun dude it's so fun that that
position specifically but it is a lot of
fun all right next year we're going to
start grappling and then half in the
middle of the half year we're going to
start mma mma [ __ ] yeah it'll just be
fun it's just it's just way more like
way scrappier like because there's just
there's there's situations where like
you know if you're kickboxing somebody
falls you turn around you wait for them
to get back up whatever grappling you
hear blah blah blah whatever but larry
like you could just throw punches at any
it's just way like [ __ ] crazier it's
fun as [ __ ] dude this one just wants to
kill people yeah it's kind of hot you're
like reminiscing
oh did you guys [ __ ] see the the the
video recently of a [ __ ] uh old
chinese man getting executioner styled
outside
they found the guy right 23 year old
dude he was a 23 year old it was in
chinatown right it was in chinatown in
chicago yeah
before i came over here so dude is
walking uh so his his wife he's 71 years
old his wife uh reads the paper and she
was gonna go out and get a paper and he
was like no it's too cold i'm gonna go
out and i'm gonna grab you the paper so
there's cc cctv cam footage of him
walking this guy rolls up on him starts
blasting at him on in the scion tc
shooting shooting at him and the guy
gets clipped the old 71 year old his
clip he crumbles through the [ __ ] to the
floor he's against the fence uh like a
home fence walks up to him execution
right in the face right in the face
[ __ ] kills him dude just and they ask
him like why'd you do it he's like it
had to be done that's the headline that
i read it had to be done yeah
and there's like no specific motive or
whatever and the guy just [ __ ]
murks him dude yeah bro it's crazy dog
like you see this [ __ ] and you're like
like what do you do what do you [ __ ]
do and that's what that's what you could
do yeah there's nothing bro like i don't
know he had like a history of like
attacking people too and then i don't
understand why is it that every time i
read these articles it's like this
person's history has a history of like
assaulting people why is he obviously
asian yeah specifically
that's what they said how old was he was
a young dude 23 years old damn he looked
like a grown ass man though there was
another lady out in new york i found
this out because chyna mack told me the
rock right yeah this lady i think he's
she's a lady i think she's also in her
70s too
[ __ ] gets put into a coma by a person
who had a brick and started smashing the
back of her head with a brick
the craziest thing i've ever heard in my
life dude you got to execute these
people bro yeah like where the [ __ ] do
these people show up next where are they
we gotta yeah we gotta put our foot down
for that i mean that never happens to
people like our age too there's always
somebody who's super [ __ ] old which
is the craziest [ __ ] thing i've ever
heard but now it's now it's the new [ __ ]
everyone's doing it i saw this uh
because part of me asked a question
sometimes it's like how much of this is
just like racial [ __ ] how much of this
is
like uh crazy people hear mental illness
yeah right and obviously they're all bad
across the board right of course but
it's just it's just you hear it so much
and you just like
kind of gets to you after a while like
like after the first one you're just
like oh my god it happens all the time
and you just hear about it and there's
it's one of those things where there's
nothing you do about it and it it sucks
yeah it sucks well the thing is too is
like yeah it's shitty i mean
i was just gonna say that like the new
that that's all the [ __ ] we see in the
news though constantly yeah i mean it's
like
don't get me wrong it's a problem like
there's [ __ ] issues but it's like
it's easy to go like that's the stuff
they know sells so like they're not
gonna talk about it's easy because i get
like that too i get jaded sometimes i'm
like dude the world [ __ ] sucks but
it's like yeah but there's actually
there's you gotta remember this like
somebody's that's definitely a
perspective
that's that's a perspective you have to
think about always because yeah you have
to remind yourself
people are actually kind of cool
sometimes too
but i saw this i saw this one
uh this older asian man like he might
have been 50 it was on i think it was in
new york in a bus and this uh this black
dude
is like yelling at him he's like you
killed my [ __ ] [ __ ] like my daughter
and he's like yelling this dude's face
he like karate chops him he's like you
broke my daughter's arm and he's like
screaming at him like grabbing him by
his neck and like shoving him and just
like and the asian dude just looking off
the guy's talking to him this way and
he's like he's like you want more you
want more and he just like nope
nope nope just do what he has to do but
then again it's just like it sucks
because you could tell this guy is
mentally ill yeah
but the other thing nobody knows and he
the asian dude is trying to do his best
by just trying to de-escalate by just
saying nope tell him everything he needs
to hear yeah or he won't do anything but
as soon as someone puts hands on this
dude like i feel like
somebody has to say something
you know
never happens i mean there's a clip
where i saw where there was a guy
he was it was at like a chinese or
vietnamese restaurant and some dude was
like harassing like the store owner or
whatever
and
what was the mma fighter that came up
yeah dude lo and behold would this guy
happen to be actual a pro mma fighter
and the guy could scrap
the way he talked to him though too was
like oh this guy is just deaf he's very
confident this yeah he's like there's
something about this dude where i was
like oh like he know he's he's really
trying hard not to kick this dude's out
he's trying
he's very confident he's gonna [ __ ] this
guy up but he didn't [ __ ] him up he
stayed calm and he just talked to him
very firmly and he stood up to the dude
walked outside they called the cops on
the guy and the guy got arrested he
called us [ __ ] out he was like why
are you doing this to him bro yeah like
like this is crazy yeah and he he did it
very well and i feel like man it sucks
that there's only one video like that
off right because that's what i'm saying
too like you know one of the things that
people always say especially in some of
the comments they go well dave you're
you're six feet tall not everybody's
gonna you know try to threaten and beat
somebody up because you're bigger i was
like i'm not telling you to fight people
yeah i'm saying when somebody calls you
a little [ __ ] in a goop look at them
and be like hey cut that [ __ ] out don't
say that [ __ ] or stand up for yourself
yeah that's kind of where it starts
because i think a lot of the times too
it's like you know i think we know a lot
of people who are guilty of this and i
used to be like this when i was younger
where you would just have somebody say
some [ __ ] and then we would just walk
off which is a which is a very smart
thing to do because why talk to stupid
people sure but when people get
aggressive and they're in your face you
can't let them do that because they're
going to just keep pushing you right
there's a line there's a line and the
way the guy did that yeah he was asking
him questions that this this uh he was
kind of drunk right yeah he was [ __ ]
up but he was asking him questions in a
way in response to what he was saying to
the the asian man to the point where he
was like he didn't know how to answer it
and it kind of disarmed him yeah a
little bit right and they tell you to do
this [ __ ] in therapy they're like when
someone says some rude [ __ ] or some
catty [ __ ] to be like hey why'd you say
that to me
most people are going to be like uh
like i don't i don't know so you know i
said this to you why did she beat you so
much
what do you mean
she assaulted you
exactly
going back to what you're saying about
like these certain things it's like yeah
you don't have to like
it's not going to fight everybody right
now
like come on dog like you know obviously
you would it would help if you knew
something and you felt confident in your
skills that would help your conversation
when you have someone because that makes
me feel way more confident when i talk
to somebody that's like could
potentially be hostile yeah it does make
you peace of mind that like okay if
something if [ __ ] were to hit the fan i
could do enough to be able to like keep
myself safe for the most part maybe not
a guarantee but good good shot yeah but
when you're talking to him it doesn't
like you do have to
like you don't have to do any you don't
have to be threatening you could just
kind of disarm the situation and
de-escalate things rather than
make it this whole like uh
[Laughter]
me
representation i mean i was a little
baked so i was like i was in the mood i
was like hey the fight scenes were cool
dope as [ __ ] but the acting little kind
of but when you watch that little corny
look corny when you watch it at home
without all just like the movie you just
have the movie on and you don't have the
rest of the experience
then certain things stand out a little
bit more hella people dm me when they
came on disney plus and they're like man
i [ __ ] kind of went hard on you on
the d i was like you're right it's not a
good movie i was like i told you you're
it's the black panther hype you got
caught up in the whole thing and you
felt that you were going to get bullied
if you said otherwise hey would you be
mad if uh
if shanghai got nominated for best
picture academy award that's cool i
don't give a [ __ ] i just i just talked
about i didn't like the movie no would
you raise an eyebrow like you know you
all know you guys are pandering oh you
know oscars i mean if
if it was your best picture i mean we
all know that's going to be [ __ ] like
everybody's going to be upset if the
wind's best picture because it didn't
even look that good especially like the
cg dragon [ __ ] looks so [ __ ] whack
the the [ __ ] uh i talked about on the
podcast but at the end of it where they
went into the the the new world and it's
just like this [ __ ] 40 square feet
area
and this [ __ ] pond that's like 3 000
feet deep
that's this is the new world yeah right
it was like you guys finished the rest
of the week yeah where where is
everybody i have a low key when i watch
that podcast so you guys going in on it
i was like come on david it's not that
serious bro but i watched it again and i
was like
hey [ __ ] david
this is my [ __ ] movie for me
yeah it was just like a little corny
like yeah just like that's cornball [ __ ]
but the fight scenes were sick as [ __ ]
yeah the first things were cool i was
like yeah yeah
the busty was great but a lot of his own
like stunts too which is [ __ ] dope
yeah the pricings were cool all right
that [ __ ] was dope you look good on
camera like because you know you get
some actors when they do like like wide
shot oh he does actually he does like
martial art [ __ ] yeah like it looks good
and then thank god they got someone that
could actually do it and make it look
good so we were at uh we did a wong fu
sketch together years ago i forgot that
we did a sketch together it was this
thing called asian bachelor this
[ __ ] we're all talking and
chatting and i look over to the right
the school just starts doing backflips
in the grass like yo guys i can do
backflips like you know what the [ __ ]
guys
he's like yoshi
yeah he starts doing flip his shirt off
it's like why is your shirt
yeah bro definitely loves attention dude
bro if you hot and you hey bro if you
hot you buff bro you gotta like keep a
shirt on dawg stay close yeah nobody
wants it it's kind of juicy huh it's
kind of like he did like a bunch of his
own stunts which is [ __ ] dude
like i said like i always say marvel
does great in casting they cast the
right people the ensemble was good yeah
i felt like everyone together that guy
wong the guy from
dude my [ __ ] he's here oh he's the
best he's the sickest yeah he's gotta
make it he gotta get his own movie right
he should get his own movie he gave you
a hug yeah we
we saw each other at this blue bayou
premiere thing and so we dm each other
every now and then he does look like he
gives good hugs
i saw him from a distance and you know
each other
and i've never actually met him face to
face and then he just looks across the
room he goes
you
come here
i'm like what the [ __ ] is this bro i
literally tear it up a little bit yeah
that's cool that's benedict cumberbatch
bro benedict cumberbatch don't you
[ __ ] dare one of them
best [ __ ] actors out there too one of
my heroes man so [ __ ] guys crazy his
name is benedict is his name really
benedict bennett
oh really yeah he's man that's correct
what are the odds he's from from the
cover benedict juan do you think they
met each other he was like great name
like dude that's super cool for sure
for sure dude great name who the [ __ ] is
named benedict between besides those two
guys huh and one of them chinese bro
that's wild that's crazy benedict arnold
kind of [ __ ] that name up huh better
yeah and then
was so defending that movie too i wasn't
defending as he was he was like it
wasn't that bad he watched it you know
what you told me that when we talked
about it you said there was too many
fight scenes
it was too many fight scenes bro because
they all blend together
like also choices were what like made it
happen for me
that was good
yeah but even then i just was like i'm
over it i'm over watching this because
sometimes it's hard to follow like yeah
the movie was too long
it should have been shorter the dad was
so disappointed all the time
though she was the only person that was
likable though
was him kill more people want to see i
want to see him go on his revenge spree
this whole was down for his highness
yeah he really was down for his time
that's tight i like that
dude he was trying to break out
because like your wife is dead says who
he's like [ __ ] up i don't know anything
i heard her last night she was
whispering my ears [ __ ] she's gonna have
rock with all the lizards coming out of
it yeah
that's where she's at she's that's where
the lizard is brought his son over hey
real talk man i saw this waterfall told
me that she alive
was like dad you're [ __ ] he's like
shut up son you don't know [ __ ] it's
like your [ __ ] wife died dude my mom
you [ __ ]
and they're like a good guy in this
movie yeah
that's why i was so mad you made the
hero look like an [ __ ] yeah his dad's
like listen i i found your mother he
goes yeah right idiot
[ __ ] [ __ ] so disrespectful he
goes you [ __ ] trained me and you told
me you loved me that's why that beat his
ass yo
my whole point was is like bro it's a
marvel movie dog marvel movies are to be
like no no no no that's not true that's
not true
america yeah avengers end game those are
like i watched the internals
i didn't watch that we're not talking
about eternals we're talking about the
first retirement i'm just talking about
iron man 2. of course captain america
civil war yeah dude that was a great how
great are those they're great they're
great but sometimes like some movies
some marvel movies they tend to be a
little some but there are a lot of great
ones of course so i hold them to that
standard yeah i agree because one of the
things too that like you know people are
writing like yo how come you uh like
these movies aren't supposed to teach
you a lesson every [ __ ] marvel film
had a more moral to the story yeah don't
lose your arm yeah [ __ ]
civil war it was about government
control like how much they have right
right right it's all about that
you know
iphone's the [ __ ] bro they're gonna get
you skynet it's a old show you know what
i mean there you go metaverse all that
[ __ ] yeah but shang chi is gonna kind of
they have a sequel coming out now
i'm curious like it was cool seeing you
know all how how he fits in with all the
other marvels
too man i feel like after
it's gonna do well like i hope there's
gonna be fun
is black panther too bro how about
chadwick bozeman ain't alive but i feel
like i feel like they're going to make
it good though they're going to make it
real good how can i take over chadwick
spot mm-hmm yeah it's true
i don't know uh
i was thinking of blade blade is going
to be this no it's going to be the the
dude from
mercenary
he kept it under wraps he was making fun
of him so hard bro
they were ripping him out david david
specifically i didn't i said no i said
no
i did not i did not i did not i forgot
what they called him it was pretty bad
though you know what's really funny is
all the memes of him saying like of him
doing this and he's like he looks pissed
yeah and they're like yo you know this
motherfucker's tired he's mad as [ __ ]
yeah sweat cancer yeah bro he shot a
whole film dude going through
chemotherapy dude it was his last film
that went on netflix and then virgil
oh yeah virgil abloh passed away and
yeah
nobody [ __ ] knew [ __ ] dude
so sad bro so what are we doing with our
livestock [ __ ] you know if i hate if i
have a song
for everybody
it's just
play the deal though
hey somebody play the deal though
but that soundtrack was fire that song
that movie was good too kendrick
everybody
was great
damn who is going to be a black panther
though i don't know man who would be a
good one who's going to fill in [ __ ]
chapel
um
yeah i don't know juicy smelly dude
i suppose
i don't know fraud or something
i mean falsifying the police report
three years bro the funniest situation
ever if you guys i mean obviously we
call it juicy spoolie because of dave
chappelle stand up one of the funniest
is that it's just one guy said his name
like that now everybody calls it juicy
smoothie not everybody can clearly read
the headline today and thought juicy
smoothie
juicy smoke
you literally have to understand like
this is real life that cannot be written
like this at all you have a crazy
light-skinned black dude right
decides to do a fake hate crime why
where somebody pretends to to make a
noose yeah and like lynch him
and the people that he hired to kidnap
him and do the whole new slash lynching
slash racial mob thing are two african
guys yeah like nigeria talking about the
most african names you've ever heard in
your life you couldn't get anybody else
you couldn't find any white guys yeah or
any other race
hilarious dude what the [ __ ] why would
you do that that's just that social
cloud social justice warriors
riding that wave right what a [ __ ]
idiot that's so crazy how powerful that
is that this guy was like oh
i'm gonna do this
and kick up some [ __ ] because remember
when every when it first came out
everybody was as you should because you
hear a story like this you're like holy
[ __ ] think about think about how much
racial tension like think about how
shitty that is how much tension he
caused in the whole country in the world
yeah to to look good himself yeah like
that's crazy that's like crazy
narcissistic
sociopath type [ __ ] that that's next
level did he plead guilty
no no he fought it i think he fought it
that's why it took three years because
he fought it for three years dude
i wonder how much time what's he do does
he do time no what happens i think it's
like he can go up to like 20 or 25 years
he literally
there he literally didn't have to go to
jail at all he created this entire
problem for himself
his life was fine isn't he good is he a
good actor
i don't know he's on power so he's like
on power
he was an actor on power popular she's a
really popular show he's doing fine
making bank killing it doing fine
well he's a crazy person that's why yeah
for sure hundred percent so let's see
what were those dudes
like when i found out that this dude was
the two guys were african i was like
dude you couldn't find anybody else and
they were the the [ __ ] most jacked
looking dudes ever really i didn't see
the guys and his [ __ ] uh lawyers
african tune nene uche
god wow he just can't stop using african
people dude
so count one guilty discount accuses him
of telling responding chicago police
officer mohammed
baig beg at around 2 45 a.m damn
some 45 minutes after the purported
attack that he was the victim of a hate
crime he said two attackers put a rope
around his neck
count two guilty this refers to smol
moulier telling i don't even know how to
perceive his actual name oh yeah
okay
supposed to be small it right yeah
something expensive it's gonna calm
juicy juicy juice was telling the same
officer he was a victim of a battery
describing attackers beating and pouring
bleach on him did he smell like bleach
first of all number one
bro your light skin is [ __ ] why would
they put bleach on you
why
you're you you're the same color as pat
bleach would do nothing that might be
darker yeah maybe it might be darker
than juicy smoothies you might be darker
than juicy would i have a hawaii roll it
might be dark
can i just say something real quick uh
all the black homies they didn't say
this publicly but they didn't believe
them at all
that's not a [ __ ] lie you know it's
funny because all the people that came
out outraged were all white people yeah
black people silent is fun dude why
they're like god but nobody's gonna play
[ __ ] bleach on this light-skinned
dude
this is full that's what gave it away
yeah like this
this will take him and he comes out the
same color in the [ __ ] out oh my god but
at 3am
right because that's that's where it
happened and it was in chicago so it's
like holy [ __ ] really cold right and
also too it was at a subway with them no
what black person goes to a subway that
late at night dude
i don't know by the way i don't know if
this is true listen i grew up in a
predominantly black neighborhood never
saw a black person in a subway ever
the only time i did is when they got the
philly cheese steak or the uh the
meatball sandwich you only see subways
near community colleges yup that's it or
just in college campuses that's right
nobody ever goes to subways and also
asian people or white people or mexican
people
bro you're on power what the hell are
you doing
at 3 a.m
yeah that goes for everybody uber eats
hey stay your ass 3 a.m you don't got
top ramen like cook himself 100 he looks
soft as [ __ ] he looks like he always
orders uber all the time oh for sure
he's walking out at 2 a.m in chicago
cold as [ __ ] to get a subway sandwich we
should ask him what we're gonna order
yeah
20 to 25 years you might do you said 20
years he deserves i think you should get
these are when smoothie made the same
claims but to a different officer
kimberly murray later that morning at
just before 6 a.m count five guilty this
accuses smalia of again telling murray
at around 7 15 p.m that he was the
victim of a battery damn you could every
time he lies he gets another count wow
so it's like you lied to a police
officer each time wow i don't think he
didn't know that either i think he
really got beat up i think count six i'm
sure not guilty so he got away with this
one not guilty this refers to smuggier
reporting on february 14th 2019 to
detective robert graves that he'd been a
victim of an aggravated battery each of
the level four felony counts smoothie
has been convicted of carries a sentence
of up to four years behind bars so it's
like 18 to 20 years then about
so 16 to 20. up to four years though
doesn't mean he has to do four yeah up
to four years oh that's why so he got
five so five times four twenty so this
jury works checks out that's [ __ ]
crazy dude hey you're you're juicy's
lawyer how do you defend him um this man
is an idiot
all right nice apologies i like this guy
right now we are trying somebody who
doesn't have a brain
do you on your good conscience want to
put this idiot
in a jail cell right with other hardened
criminals he's a muggaloid idiot
let me tell you something everybody this
man has the softest hands i've ever felt
in my life yeah he slapped me the other
day because i told him what i was going
to say today and let me tell you
something i didn't even feel it
yeah
it felt good legit felt like feathers
this guy is a [ __ ] yeah bang and you
don't put a [ __ ] in jail they're like i
don't think we should put this [ __ ] in
jail
not a single sign of color in it at all
wow he bleaches his butthole he bleaches
anybody
you think juicy smelly bleachers sure
hundred percent yeah he told me that
when they threw bleach on him he just
opened up his butt and said i think do
it for free anyways he said thanks guys
thank you so much thanks he's gonna do
it anyways
i just can't believe i want to know how
he hired these dudes like where did he
find them from craigslist
who knows that's right
i need somebody to pretend to do a hate
crime on me there's a paper trail
comes out i'll do it
could you be wise
so the guy the guys that he hired
obviously turned they told that he
obviously wow what a [ __ ] what they talk
they must have they ratted them out they
must have because how else are they
gonna really they didn't know they were
like hey can you just like beat me up
and just trying to like play it off and
he didn't know what they were he was
gonna say to the media that'd be fun it
might have been like that honestly it
might have been like that they might he
might have been like hey i'm just paying
you to like [ __ ] me up and they're like
all right how much do you think he paid
him is there a record of that
uh yeah i feel like it had to be like a
thousand dollars or something can't be
that much dude
okay so here this this is their names
oh wait come on how much would somebody
have to pay you to do that bat
like it same situation same story hits
you up and he's like yo oh he's gay too
who juicy smelly is gay yeah he said he
was the gay tupac
hey bro he self-proclaimed that he is
the gay two
yeah i was just driving on this phil
said he's a gay tupac i for some reason
thought that yeah but he he did that's
what that's when the two black dudes
were like we got to wrap this
[ __ ]
they saw that interview they're like oh
we gotta we gotta tell the media i mean
those guys actually like they got a
thousand dollars they got led up i mean
they got they had to go through a hassle
for a little bit obviously getting
interrogated but once they just checked
on the guy
i do it for like 20 g's 20 g's
i want to do that [ __ ] for 1500 bro
1200. someone comes up to you with 20
g's i believe yeah and then i just tell
on you and when the cops arrest me i'll
be like that guy paid me to do this but
i i hid the money so they can't get it
and then i just
tell him oh he paid me a thousand
dollars he paid me in bitcoin oh my god
so
this is getting access so he faced so he
at trial jurors heard from brothers
oh
that pronunciation african people on
earth yeah what who said smoothie that's
a spell or he destroyed the attack
himself and paid them 3 500 to carry it
out thirty five hundred thirty five
hundred dollars
said the check was for a meal and a and
workout plan from abimbola a friend and
an extra on empire oh he was an extra
empire there you go that's how you met
him a tv drama about a hip-hop dynasty a
hip-hop night asked by his defense story
if he gave the man payment for the
alleged scheme smoothie replied never
he also testified that he and abby bola
were involved in a sexual relationship
before the 11 alleged attack so they
[ __ ] [ __ ] then they did it
get the [ __ ] out of here wow that's
pretty tight so wait so he's saying
that's not a good deal bro would you say
that this was a racial hate crime or
like because he was gay it was both no i
think it was racial it was the gay thing
did they get
the thing that the thing that took the
spotlight though was the racial thing
because they said he said they were
wearing maga hats
bleaching him
uh this is maggot country type [ __ ] like
that it was
like ra ra the race thing was what was
being oh that's right this is maga
country i thought that at the end
i thought they i thought he covered all
his bases at the end they said look at
the statement he said
word you know to the guys after he was
how would they know who he is yeah who
how would they know i think that was
yeah that's true and first of all if
they were white how many white people
you know watch [ __ ] empire yeah right
exactly because i didn't even know who
[ __ ] juicy smoothie wasn't until this
[ __ ] yeah imagine you're a trump
supporter you're watching empire yeah
yeah
no you're not your priorities [ __ ] you
you don't know i'm fine
but their tower is so good in this i
just pictured just juicy smoothies just
coaching them like hey when you come up
to me make sure you say the f word yeah
and get rid of that african accent yeah
i want it to be gone this is maga
no you're not doing it right
what if they did a self tape
juicy's behind the camera he's like no
wind it up a little bit yeah
[Applause]
risk risk i don't know why you are here
in my country no no no
no that's too african you are not i
don't know why you're not in my country
like something's like why would he not
hire white dudes i don't know
he was too scared because he this was an
extra on set and i bet you they they
probably did have a romantic
relationship so after they hooked up he
was like hey i need you to do me a favor
i thought i was fool proof i need you to
just pretend to be a white person oh my
god and then throw some bleach on me
with the whole news thing i'll pay you 3
500 bucks it'll be quick i'm i'm gonna
make a [ __ ] ton more money you know he
was making a hundred thousand dollars
per episode oh
it wasn't on
100k per episode and by the way jail
jail i'm not sure if power is still
going but they have like spin-offs right
but i think you're mixing up empire and
power
oh is it are they different shows you
said i think he's on empire i don't
think he's on power powers how is the
show that gianni is on oh that's all
why are they all they like they have
like three vampire they have three
different ones oh they're the same show
to me though
they are i thought they were about the
music industry
like drugs and and ghosts yeah okay so
empire is oh my bad empire p henson and
terence howard is empire
ah that's what that is but i think he
was on empire i'm pretty sure he's okay
it's empire then that's the 50 cent show
power 50 i don't know if he does 50 cent
does power god damn it
love
hate
power
i want to see the self tape that he is
like i need you to audition for this
role
yeah give me your notes
i'm going to throw bleach on your face
no no just don't do it don't actually
don't say it just do it i want you to
just not do the african part and be
white again
how well can you tie a noose here we go
yeehaw
fireball that's pretty good that's
pretty good take it
throw the noose on them
but i'm surprised it took three [ __ ]
years dude yeah
yeah what more evidence do you need this
guy clearly lied to the guys are african
also and they ratted him out why did why
do
i mean if you're gonna pretend to do
something why do you need somebody to
actually like you could just do it
yourself and then just say some white
dudes attacked me don't report it to the
police and then just have it up in the
air be like hey man i was at a subway
and some guy called me the f word yeah
and said that we don't like your black
people around here and i hate the show
empire it's just like power yeah exactly
it's just like power right right it's
easily what's the difference yeah
they're like what's the difference
between you're saying that all black
people look alike and then then we had a
seven hour conversation and then he
threw bleach in my face yeah he probably
didn't think the attacker went in though
on the show he was like season one was
good but season two started falling off
your acting kind of slipped a little bit
your character choice absolutely abysmal
yeah yeah boom abysmal anyways maggot
country
country
country
but i feel like you could openly say
anything about juicy now and it's all
good yeah because i mean he deserves the
biggest piece of [ __ ] because especially
during that time things were even now
things are so hot when it comes to
racial tensions yeah we don't need the
fake stories the real stuff already is
bad enough yeah bro right we don't need
the extra [ __ ] literally you are
going to hell so fast bro yeah like what
are you doing like why you want that so
bad just to look like a good person i
guess or just be like so like what is
this full doing looking at the news and
then you see like a mod arbor you get
murdered he's like i wish that was me
what's he doing dude what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
even that thing bro like some i don't
know how the court system works but for
the the juicy small yay i was like isn't
that open and shut is it the ahmad
marbury opening case that's open and
shut bro yeah like that's murder that's
okay
yeah like when i heard it was like oh
it's in trial again i was like what for
what they like hunting this guy down
like an animal i was like they didn't
close this book last year when it
happened yeah like that's open and shut
case yeah that's crazy
like hey so why were you chasing them uh
i don't know did you see that part where
their [ __ ] defense lawyer was like
did you see the the dirty toes but like
this man had filthy toenails yeah like
talk about the most racist thing that
you could say this man deserved to die
because his feet are dirty nobody threw
the whole that whole side of the room in
contempt i said i see them do that in
the movies yeah that's when you throw
something in contempt
as a lawyer how could you
even say that if you saw that clip right
she goes like his unkept dirty toenails
and then it goes to uh a cut of the guys
were the defendant and they're just
mortified they're like why would you see
that yeah let's check their toenails cuz
it's the most racist thing basically
you're saying that why don't you dirty
black man in his dirty feet you might as
well just said that you [ __ ] cut back
why would you say that
nobody knows she'd lose her license dog
she should not be able to do law what
was their defense what was the defense
because they clearly hunted him down
like what would i mean her closing
statement was basically saying the way
the media portrayed them it wasn't the
way that it actually was and then she
put the nail in the coffin talking about
his dirty unkept toes didn't they go on
facebook live and stream it yeah they
were streaming hey
so it was don't stream yourself
committing murder y'all sure so the
three it was three people it wasn't even
just two so it was two the two guys in
the trunk and the guy that was recording
it
the [ __ ] modern day lynching oh my
god bro like
the fact that uh dude [ __ ] it's never
chased them down it was like they might
as well have just replaced the [ __ ]
truck with two horses
and then just have a noose at the end of
it it was the most mortifying thing i've
ever seen in my life that [ __ ] as well
what what was the reason for chasing him
uh so he was
so he's an athlete he jogs around the
neighborhood sure and he doesn't belong
in the neighborhood and then he he they
saw him walk into a construction site of
a house being built and then he just
jogged out and that's it yeah and they
chased him and then it's like this guy's
trying to rob people and they chased him
down with a shotgun
in a truck didn't they try to say that
they were they thought he was someone
that was nearby that committed a crime
at like a like a robbery or something
wasn't that the initial story because i
remember it was like they tried to use
that as like a reason
to like go
like oh well we found the guy he was the
guy that robbed the store down the
street i remember that was like one of
the early uh i don't know if it's still
the dude is like in athletic jogging
gear too by the way he's exercising yeah
damn dude crime exercising while black
and even if he was stealing some [ __ ] at
the house it's a construction site y'all
gonna shoot him yeah right you're gonna
kill me
call the cops you batman dude like what
is this this is crazy and by the way he
walked into a developing home it's like
it's like on sticks and now what's he
gonna steal there's nothing in there
yeah this guy was stealing [ __ ] two
by fours
this he was stealing nails put in his
pocket yeah
he stole four screws and two two by
fours this [ __ ] little [ __ ] god yeah
do they get life do they get life for
sure or death penalty got something
though
it was it was pretty bad
it's murder they should just let people
chase them down and [ __ ]
yeah forever that's what i think
eye for an idea just lame too just dude
that why isn't that getting pressed
bro
keep seeing i keep seeing little
articles though they're wild like you
know why they're seeing like the people
that are attached to the heavy hitters
and they're the ones that run everything
they run into media
they got money and twitter they got
money in the banks they got money
everywhere and these are the people and
also the the charge that they're being
charged on is from 1999 to two describe
everybody with the whole gizzly maxwell
thing
jeffrey epstein is a very
prominent child sex trafficker him and
his
partner jizlane maxwell
who is chip who was the first thought to
be his girlfriend but now seems like she
was actually the master of his partner
she seemed like she was like now the
more things come out like it seems like
he was more the puppet she was kind of
running the show her dad was like
involved with some intelligence agency
too and like there's a whole it goes
deep it goes deep deep deep and this is
the one where they would have that
private island epstein island they had
they had ties with donald trump bill
clinton bill gates
and this goes on they were having sexual
relations with young girls yeah so they
were they were
targeting young women
that are 14 16
well under 18.
they're targeting them
uh gelane was trying to groom them
and then eventually
epstein would sexually assault them and
then they became they were they're
paying these girls because they knew
these some of these girls the one the
girls that testified last week
she was like under a jane doe and she
was talking about how her father died
from a sickness when she was like 14
mom was single
working and they just didn't have enough
money to do anything
jeffrey epstein swooped in at the high
school that she was going to like some
performing arts high school started
talking her made a connection started
paying her grooming her yada yada yada
next thing she knows she's like
having sex with like she's getting she's
pretty much getting trafficked right
and that's been the case that she's
they've been doing over and over and
they have all these documentaries all
these documentaries are explained way
more in detail
and way more horrific things that he did
than we could ever also they taped they
had security cameras on the island and
they would like bring important
influential people there and they had
like this database loki they're like do
they have did they have well i don't
know who has it i don't know if the
government i don't know what that is the
government they're not going to release
it they're not no the thing is is a lot
of people think that it was like a
blackmail thing like because they were
involved with some intelligence agencies
so it was like sexual basically if i get
a scientist like a top scientist to come
over i got a video of him [ __ ] a kid
now it's like yo own you now you say
global warming is not real
because i own an oil company out you
know what i mean like you you ca and
right now science is like the religion
so there was a lot of top scientists
that they were they were doing that to
but also politicians movie like kevin
spacey was like called on there a lot
chris tucker was one of the names i saw
on the plane too i was like chris tucker
he was a random yeah i was like
but like a lot of people were i was like
damn that's [ __ ] wild but who knows i
mean who knows it's a numbers game i
think what the deal is but i think they
were just trying to get in positions
where
to influence obviously to to control
whatever
and run whatever agenda they wanted
to do
with jeffrey epstein too is like he was
a millionaire but nobody knew how he got
his money so a lot of people think
there's a conspiracy that
uh gallane maxwell's
father was a head of i forgot what the
it was like british intelligence not it
was something along those lines but i
think it was it wasn't british it was
middle east somewhere in the middle east
israeli israeli intelligence that's what
it
was
and then
her sister glenn maxwell's sister
actually created the um database
software for the fbi so like they're
just what like they're just in every
facet they're everywhere yeah so a lot
of the theories were was that
nobody knew how epstein got all this
money so a lot of people think that it's
from blackmail it's from maybe being
funded by
his lane
and he would use his money and he was
like just like he was kind of like some
of them described him as like a playboy
millionaire type that would just like he
was he had his hands on all these
different pots
so a lot of the science community a lot
in
um like politics he was he was rubbing
elbows with these people so a lot of it
could be he was trying to get close to
them hey come to my island i'll show you
[ __ ] good time mr
bill clinton i know you like the [ __ ]
here's this island of
girls that we could do whatever we want
no one's going to say [ __ ] and i think
that's a lot of the pretense of how he
got these people over like prince andrew
prince andrew's one of them he is a dude
from the royal family dufresne is the
girl that had like one of the biggest
cases about
um
epstein talk about a slave owner's name
huh yeah georgia dufresne but she
she was the girl that was being abused
by prince andrew
and she was like and he this
[ __ ] was on the interview with
uh that's the one where his shit's all
[ __ ] up and he's like sweating yeah
and they're asking him like do you know
who this girl is and it's a him on the
island with this like 16 year old girl
and her name is georgia dufresne which
is like the most popular one of the most
virginia i think
yeah anyway so and he's like
ah yeah can't recall i don't know who
she is and this chicken was like
like imagine this chick bro she's like
that's a great maker
like
rachel right me when i was like 16 17
multiple times and and he he kept coming
back for me did you see that there was a
there was an interview like about a
month ago with bill gates like he's on
some news thing i think they're talking
about covet or something but then for
some reason the reporter brings up like
hey so the epson because bill gates has
been known to like affiliate with uh
with epstein and that was like one of
the reasons i think that his ex-wife
cited in terms of breaking up with him
was because they had a relationship
and the reporter brings up like so what
do you like what do you how do you feel
like people know that you you've been on
the plane and like you had a
relationship what's going on he tries to
play it off he's like yeah i didn't know
blah blah blah
yeah yeah yeah and then she's like yeah
she like asked a follow-up question and
his response is he literally says well
he's dead now so and he kind of tries to
like brush off well now he's dead so and
he kind of tries to like move the
conversation on it's like dude
you obviously had something to do with
that [ __ ] or you knew about it you're
like what kind of response is like yeah
he's dead [ __ ] it you know and he kind
of chuckles and he's like all right
let's go who says that bro who says that
if you had nothing to do with it who's
just chilling
trafficked on an island and he goes
well he's dead he's dead like okay aka
shut the [ __ ] up so shut the [ __ ] up and
also there's an interesting statistic
that came out of i think it was either
2020 or 2021 it was like i think it was
anywhere from like 100 to 200 million
dollars that bill gates has sent to
media funds
so like all these different media
uh oh yeah oh yeah
it's like oh we're like we're like
living in a real life conspiracy theory
that's like coming like this is the
biggest it's like a big conspiracy
theory that's like real that's like oh
[ __ ] this shit's true well this is just
it's getting no press i've seen
popular conspiracy theory by far well
it's it's one of the most credible ones
where it's like it's most widespread
like everyone's like oh yo this is
[ __ ] up well there's other conspiracy
theories that have come true that we
just like the nsa spying on you like
that that used to be a conspiracy theory
sure they're like they're not [ __ ]
pain they don't read your text they
don't have a database for your [ __ ] yeah
they do all that how come i said bra
once and i had 17 bra ads yesterday huh
yeah is this
the [ __ ] dude it was weird like when
you start getting into the episode stuff
it's kind of scary because it's like
holy [ __ ] really too because i mean if
people are wondering why it's not big i
mean if bill clinton is paying off all
these [ __ ] outlets how many other
people are yeah but you can't control
genius brain though unless you want to
give me a few million dollars
just pay me episode what 290. all this
stuff is conspiracy [ __ ] guys
andrew is fine
beautiful wonderful woman dude hasn't
trafficked anything the only thing that
has to do with traffic or her [ __ ]
tickets that she's got that's about it i
feel like you could say not any any any
rude [ __ ] about women about gizlane
maxwell and it's all good yeah because
she tears
yeah
it's all good you could be as
misogynistic as we want to hurt yours
but that's what i think she'll get us
killed
people are really understanding too like
not everything is what it seems like
right and sometimes parents is bliss
because when you start to realize like
how much money is involved in stuff too
and i've talked about even like
hollywood this is why i [ __ ]
listen like i i'm auditioning for roles
or whatever right but there's also this
huge dark side to hollywood that
everybody talks about yeah and
and even in the dark side of this it's
not that big of a deal but how many
people [ __ ] go up to somebody's
[ __ ] and then sucks the poop out of
it
it's an unholy cleanse baby i always
talk about it just it's just you see it
so often i've seen so many people in
front of my face talk [ __ ] about
somebody and then in the same party i'll
walk around and they're talking that
person sure gassing them up oh man the
last the last project you want was so
amazing yeah funny you literally just
told me that they're a trash actor yeah
why are they always just projects too
yeah
i'm wearing this one project it's like
it's talking about a movie dog called tv
show car tv show [ __ ] yeah it's called
a tv show tv show i mean even like
weinstein like he wasn't the only one
he's for sure he's not the only one
there's all kinds of crazy [ __ ] still
happening
dude bill cosby you're walking around
free right now dude that's so crazy oh
yeah he got let out huh yeah he got let
out he's walking around free forgot
about that how come no one was like
let him out i don't know but when he was
first president they threw a jello
pudding at him though
that's hilarious dude somebody will just
wait and do it he's like this would be
[ __ ] funny without this [ __ ]
coming here watch this [ __ ] guys jello
pudding pop boom hits him in the head
[Music]
i think it was just jello pudding that
they still out there in general okay
okay i thought he had like a brand of
jello pudding dude jello pudding pops
fire like paul newman the the lemonade
guy you know the guy why is that guy on
the lemonade i thought he bill cosby had
that for jello pudding no i think he
just did the commercials he got a fat
[ __ ] check for it
you know what i'm talking about talking
he was like why is this guy on the
lemonade isn't he a singer paul newman
paul newman was an actor or uh a golfer
or some [ __ ] see those kendrick lamar
[ __ ] uh chocolate covered
strawberries
you open it up it's just him rapping
dude
it's hilarious well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
shout outs to juicy smoothies
hey come on the podcast juicy cheers
love you very much uh juicy when you get
out of prison in 20 years uh come on
here i'll give you a subway sandwich and
see if you eat it dude
delight yeah it's gonna be a turkey
light extra avocado hold the mayo pull
out the bread on the inside
yeah and if you don't eat that [ __ ] we
know it's a real lie yeah you don't eat
subway [ __ ]
you can catch nick at nick the ear and
you can catch patrick at patrick.
somebody got good sugar cookies though
oh you just love [ __ ] floor cookies
dude
you and floor
gas over bro
stupid we'll see y'all next time peace